il s'agit d'une scène supprimée appelée
mauvaise direction et vous remarquerez que cela
présente de la joie et de la peur que nous appelions
Freddie à l'époque et les deux
sont ceux par opposition à la joie dans la
tristesse qui a fait tout ce voyage
dans cette version le long du  façon qu'ils
découvrent ou bing-bong et c'était l'une
des premières apparitions de Bing bong dans
le film il y vivait avec les autres
amis imaginaires dans cette sorte de
village clochard qu'ils avaient une bonne dans un
petit campement il y a ces grands
riches  les personnages qui étaient les favoris de Riley
c'était une séquence amusante à jouer
avec cela fonctionne toujours oui le
petit ami imaginaire de Riley je mourrais pour
Riley Wow toujours intense maintenant vous les gars avez l'
air familier nous avions l'habitude de nous cacher et
le placard de Riley il avait une bonne course ce que
vous pouvez  j'ai la maison à côté de la mienne c'est
un peu petit mais il y a
une cheminée qui fonctionne ouais il y a eu une
erreur je ne suis pas à la retraite je suis toujours une grande
partie de la vie de Riley tu verras il n'y a
rien de mal à être  un peu de
prédilection